continuamos haciendo conversiones de
funciones cartesianas a polares y en
este caso ahora vamos a trabajar con la
función 3d menos 7 x igual a 10
veamos qué podemos hacer queremos
convertir esto a r y theta y lo primero
que vamos a hacer pues es sustituir lo
que ya tenemos aquí para xy así que
vamos a hacer la sustitución y esto nos
quedará 3
pero ya es simplemente el seno de teta
menos 7 x pero os x es sería 7 r coseno
de teta esto es igual a 10 todo esto
salió de nuestras identidades
trigonométricas y ahora vamos a intentar
simplificar esto y escribirlo en
términos de teta escribimos ahora con el
factor común como r
tres veces el seno de teta menos siete
veces el coseno de peta es igual a 10 en
ambos lados podemos dividir por este
factor y nos quedarán en que eres igual
a 10 dividido entre tres veces el seno
de teta menos 7 veces el coste de no
detecta y en fin ustedes ven ahora
tenemos una función de teta ahora r es
una función de teta y ya terminamos
perfecto pues vayamos al siguiente en el
siguiente nos va a decir bueno primero
pegamos nuestras fórmulas que las
tenemos a la mano y entonces ahora
tenemos que nuestro ejercicio nos dice
que ya será igual a 2x menos 3 ahora lo
vamos a escribir en términos de rey teta
por lo que ya que es igual a rc no
detecta será igual a 2 veces x pero x es
jose no detecta -3 ahora lo que voy a
hacer es agrupar y voy a pasar este
término restando por lo que me quedara r
se no detecta menos dos veces r jose no
detecta esto es igual a menos tres ahora
voy a volver a reagrupar como en el
ejercicio anterior y r que multiplica
hace no detecta menos dos veces el coce
no de teta es igual a menos tres y
finalmente voy a pasar este terminó
dividiendo para dejar a la erre sola y
esto es que eres igual a menos 3
dividido entre el seno de teta menos 2
veces el coche no detecta y como pueden
observar tengo otra vez una función de r
en términos de teta
ahora vamos a borrar nuestra pantalla la
ponemos en negro
vamos a traer otra vez nuestras
identidades básicas y ahora vamos a
hacer un ejercicio que sea al revés
nuestra función polar ahora es r igual a
4 veces el seno de teta y queremos
convertirlo a algo en términos de xy así
que pues no es tan inmediato y vamos a
ver qué es lo que tenemos por aquí ya
ver por ejemplo aquí tenemos r seno de
teta y parece que este sería un buen
punto para empezar o sea que voy a
escribir
james iguales a ese no detectan y ahora
vamos a dividir ambos lados entre r así
que me queda que llegue entre r es igual
al seno de teta y bueno este pues al
menos empieza a pintar que esto ya es
hacia dónde queremos ir así que ahora
vamos a reemplazar lo que tenemos aquí y
nos va a quedar que r
va a ser igual a 4 veces se no detecta
pero seno de teta es de entre r a ver
ahora veamos qué tal si multiplicó en
ambas el lados por r y me queda r
cuadrada igual a 4 y aquí tenemos una
expresión para r cuadrada así que
tenemos que x cuadrada más y cuadradas
es igual a 4 g
y con eso estamos listos lo obtuvimos de
una manera implícita no explícita pero
bueno podemos continuar muy bien
con estas herramientas que estamos
trabajando y estamos observando que es
mucho trabajo de álgebra es mucha
manipulación algebraica por lo que
sigamos haciendo ejemplos traemos
nuestras herramientas y en nuestra
ecuación polar esta vez es r igualase no
detectan más coseno de theta podemos
graficar esto y podríamos utilizar una
calculadora gráfica y poner esta
ecuación y ver qué es lo que produce de
hecho yo no tengo una intuición ahorita
de cuál sería el resultado de lo
importante es que si la transformamos a
coordenadas x hiciéramos la gráfica
obtendríamos exactamente lo mismo no
sabemos si son pétalos de una flor o
bueno eso ya veremos qué sería
ahora vamos a resolverla para eso vamos
a utilizar estas dos últimas relaciones
que tenemos aquí y vamos a dividir entre
r de manera que tengamos el seno de teta
quedará igual y entre r y éste lo mismo
para la de aquí abajo nos va a quedar
que el cose no de teta es igual a equis
entre r lo tomamos de esta relación que
está aquí ahora vamos a reemplazar en
nuestra ecuación de arriba y nos quedará
que r es igual al seno de teta pero el
seno del pp entre r más el coce no
detecta pero de aquí vemos que es x
entre r lo siguiente que vamos a hacer
es multiplicar por r ambos lados de
manera que ahora tenemos re cuadrada es
igual a más x pero ya sabemos quién es r
cuadrada de aquí arriba ya sabemos que x
cuadrada más
que lo que está aquí así que era de
cuadrada ahora será igual hay más x
y ya terminamos ahora vamos a hacer otro
esta vez este a ver voy a escoger otro
color
no voy a poner a nuestras ecuaciones y
este que sea r iguala a cuadrada o sea
que esto ya sabemos por la experiencia
pasada que esto es un círculo si a vale
3 pues entonces sería r igual a 9 que
sería pues un círculo de radio 9 y así
sería con cualquier otro valor que le
diéramos a a y lo vamos a manejar así de
abstracto entonces ahora conocemos que x
cuadrada más cuadrada es igual a erre
cuadrada en nuestro problema de
pitágoras y entonces en ambos lados
elevaremos al cuadrado de manera que
tendremos r cuadrada igual a la cuarta o
sea al elevar al cuadrado al cuadrado me
queda a la cuarta entonces ahora
reescribo x cuadrada más cuadrada igual
a la cuarta y ya estamos no estuvo nada
mal en los siguientes vídeos vamos a
explorar cómo graficar estas relaciones
y también vamos a entender un poco más
cuál es la relación entre
y está bueno pues hasta aquí en este
vídeo nos vemos en el siguiente